okay after ahmadies what's the flavor
care two policies in the offense hope
you guys are doing well
update on the larger marriage
documentary and about one good news for
you guys
it'll keep you guys know going to put in
wrap it up as you guys know that it's on
delayed something to issue a stolen car
broken into blah blah blah we are china
best to get myself into I'll see you
guys it's really clean for everything we
want to be like the watch and I want to
do the best job I can I don't want to
rush it put out any light on benefit yet
I want to do it properly and it is well
inshallah to everything wanna be like
benefit now just so getting the best
buys up a bit more excited I'm going to
tell you guys the content that's going
to be in there
I feel you like reflux Lloyd's role so
I'm going to briefly tell you guys about
some content I'll be sharing impact with
you as you guys know the struggle I will
do everything one of us go through this
knowing for the right person I've missed
many sicknesses absolutely didn't work
out lovely sisters may Allah bless them
all and give them the best in the
hereafter those who are grieving
disagreed with have some conflict well
if it may be but we all coffee that
things looking for partner over partner
meeting meeting meeting what whether or
not going well and you want to give up
in control point where you spend I don't
really mind anymore you come across
wrong individuals idea must run
individual I team up was wrong
individual I will ask the wind question
which put me off affected my team and I
came across racism one Somali Somali
discover objected by family wonderful
now is very chancy stuff go rejected by
family I had times where I just what you
know what I don't know how much more I
can very good you know the kind of limit
is hard it's hard unhappy period because
it's a sexualized environment even me
fear for myself I said look I just want
to get married do this on our way to
your chance it so I'm going to discuss
with you guys how I deal with it when I
came home and something might happen I
was on the map crying to my lord you
know and something might say okay are
crying management
the rubbish I applied to my world one
equated me
and nothing to be ashamed of we all go
through struggles how I deal with it
for example financially when I was in
financial troubles
I want my family with against me marina
HIV owned me I didn't I didn't say I
just want to marry judge I preferred it
to my sister to do whether a job as well
but I said McCracken he'll be glad in
accept any without discussing the matter
document I want to give too much away
yet so the discussion that how I deal
with it how I deal with my family my dad
not wanted me to marry a sister sister
is a Muslim you know kind of convincing
going through madness going through
racism goals and financial strongarm in
discussing with I've also be disruptive
it's too hard
how to do is the harder I don't know
what we're going to do stuff I'm going
to vote we breathing don't know how to
do mr. hodda I will tell you guys step
by step when you do is to hide us how to
do stir harder and what's the procedure
what was made are also be discussing
that I also be telling you guys that
madness over to our catfish if you like
work a thesis a sister prefer to me for
marriage
using somebody else's pictures but the
system actually real somebody else
pitted however I was just telling you
guys about the things you start who said
that she threw herself out the window
yes she said that she threw herself out
the window
yes because her family would wouldn't
allowing us to get married and this
whole madness or it was crazy right
someone trying to out the window and
then we like in racing I'm a little
inside that is well yet also also
rejection not one of the big things that
I personally found it hard is when I'll
unpack move on the sister how do I say
no it was hard for me or for example
dealing with rejection
when assisted in a finally compatible
breath how do i do without rejection and
when we get is people call objections
but then I believe there's a great
wizard
change it you don't answer it we
shouldn't see it as rejection but a
blessing in this one is that make sense
here I'll be talking about that how to
deal with that I also be share with you
guys yes for example I would hang on the
symbolism
yes I would and I will tell you I'll be
showing you guys my profile picture yet
you guys let me laughing head about
where and I was my vibration was just
like well I don't know internet you
might be laughing at that I'll be
sharing that with you I'll be telling
you guys is it good to get to know
somebody on social media which website
to look for which ones to look out for
which one's the fader hell away from
going to management
I want the management yes we sit down
for success for balance and-- mother the
woodies are there as well I went there
is it goes is it work out I'll be
telling that this world you guys I'm
sharing that with you guys world also
social media can we get to know someone
for social media in Italy well me
personally I've been approached this in
the social media that sounds compatible
for myself how do I go about that how
did I do that how did I potion was it
right was it good was it bad also
approaching people in public for example
we live in a society where when I see it
to start up interested in yes you should
lower of capons he's going to get
married right you know nobody can go and
get you know binoculars there oh you're
gonna translate no but if you see a
sister how do I go about the right way
well we asked the question to mostly men
yes whooping men we often in today's age
or younger up let's say like mr. Wakile
a bit younger how do I go and if I see
successes that I like warmest waters in
follow her to a house and then I go
ahead and say onto our I just waited for
our daughter from bloody Whitechapel so
yeah boom gets up in your face yeah how
do we go about it when we approach the
sister ourself obviously for marriage
purposes only how to go about that
secondly secondly also for sister's
sister see the profit that she like how
would you go about it you know should
she call approach in should you get
somebody else's etc all this mostly
makes tells us how to go about it
also I was discussing when things are
when you really want to murder one and
it doesn't go right how'd you do with it
how do you just rebel
no how would the ratleys do with it a
lot people only this is just some of the
content you know there's some sort of
content our also also know show we've
also shown you guys my would be ma yes
I'm going to show you guys my Willie ma
obviously an ability my white face for
the Sangha members whenever they open up
but you will see a preview of the window
please one little bit will be mark how
it went in Charlotte I'm going to share
that with you guys
very briefly that's about it so keep it
out be patient
there wasn't Sharma so healing now good
news
number two swiftly moving on yes now
guys at exactly one of the business
problems that we have in today's time is
going like we have questions we have
these questions for example I'm a new
river I've got tattoos can I remove them
they go case I keep them doing business
in for that assistant Mike honestly I
work at it goes sometimes afterglow pork
or alcohol is this permissible a blah
blah I'm a bus driver and sometimes I
cannot stop and praise the Lord as a
mother how do I go out it we need these
questions answered for example how do
you call the right way about divorce
also what's the public is Akash what is
the correct way to pay how do I
calculate it
these are questions that all rough up
but we need to go to reliable people to
get our answer our progress is November
we need to bow to the people of
knowledge right the or lemma yes we are
Allah not all around the world but
specific ones for example we are we're
fullest in Saudi Arabia which we know
under a lot and the people around they
are not mercy on them and we go there we
are promised that art on our behalf but
sometimes we need
solace in our own land we need
individuals that we can go up to and ask
them this is a problem this is a problem
so I found a little solution right now
no one of us or lovely I don't come to
become a nobody yes I a zero and I
refuse to be humble I am nobody
don't take nothing from me nothing if I
compute it around her upset throw it in
the bin I mean I want nobody yeah so
okay so guys the one of the most
reliable thoughts that we have in the
united kingdom a sigma have that right
now now that i want to give you guys
that we need to understand cuz i'm going
to open approaching and our key
questions you have a right to know who
is the share who is a study under what
is this clarification right you have a
right to opposite something that you
reside with please introductions with so
designers you don't know and much and
you don't know these scholars i'm
program at much my slide right over your
head but to scale with me
so you guys can have it understand it
and can check out these big ulama right
sure Iijima like that i studied studied
under share the abdullah even a key
right you spend with the share directly
for 13 years and we're sure hey Tim
Driscoll number is Studies on a lot 10
years bubbles who is in contact [ __ ]
I believe inaccurate one business one of
the one of us in Saudi Arabia we are not
have mercy on him I hate him Spanish
Spanish started studying with him in
1991 or not for 13 years yes and also
chef even a cute would have basically
that is all based they would write
letters they have no text or email so
they will write letters and he would be
a very he would like to listen to share
of they means him a lot share what they
mean one of the biggest will enough yes
I was I wanted insulin apartheid
check with a means teacher this water no
from service area is shut up to Rahman
absolutely right he is the teacher of
she's a chef or chef Cosentino to
mention she wrote a nice teacher so she
hated feature shared with Akhil appeal
would write let's battle for our team
question right so this was always week
were worker the attention of chef Hayden
actually some said white will come home
with letters this question your team
convincing socialism was one of the
individuals who came up with ideas on
how invested in a book format this book
was widely spread and praised the
amazing positive feedback and was
praised by many scholars whose favor men
:
and one of those
he praised this book yes Pandora so I'm
talking about any new - achievement had
that a book that the listen that he put
forth yet has would prefer sheriffing me
right I'm also sure he's also studied
with share image appear that he studied
the book from betánia or party that
stood Maria Akiva a key that says Maria
others up transfer right he they
completed to the book in the last time
he spent with the Buddha chef besh at
him studied with his other titration
energy dream 4:11 yet this is the same
share this distinction in a gathering he
pointed out Sheraton and said this man
is an island
this man is an admin right and this
shows you who share intimate right
you've been played by these colors now
obviously all of us all of them but one
of the businesses are speak him too
shall hate them and generally asking for
its introduction in 1992 he studied the
Sheraton study which has been bad rahim
allah shares in bad if you guys don't
know you need to know to share about
this but one of the biggest will amount
our time share feedback may Allah have
mercy on him
Shaitan Spanish with him about 11 years
11 yet until the chef's passed away and
only later moved to London and also she
hate hate matter that but it roughly
about one and a half to two years with
the current Mufti of Saudi Arabia who is
also known as Abdul Aziz and share share
hasten study also within his predation
called further but I just want to give
you guys a brief introduction to the
chef that we are going to be getting
these fatwa and these Macias from now on
with the new series with the new new
show so guys I'm going to give you guys
an emergence and let that give you guys
limitless when you guys can send all
your emails to send your questions to
this interval the first one that we will
see so far is from a system not to
husband's me yet
you heard it right she's got
- husband we're going to tell you how
she said into that and also share it
with them tell us how she can fix that
and not to fall into that game and you
guys can benefit or how to go about the
right way of divorce so that is going to
be our first topic on our first show
very soon inshallah so guys keep
shooting that's about it for me we're
are blessed everything one of you guys
may Allah grant you guys joined
inshallah send your questions in here
and we will be giving you your messy -
Allah and also by the way guys I'll be
deciding about what I'm going to call
the show yeah the name of the show so if
you have any good ideas under the
section below a marketing so okay
islamic market or a schedule may Allah
bless everyone
[Music]